welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy with one pair
of clothes shout outs myself
and the suicide squad trailer is finally
here now i've just done a big
25 minute breakdown on falcon in the
winter soldier i'm doing
another 20 minute one on invincible at
the moment so i just thought
you know i'd i'd do a nice little
breakdown that doesn't take much work
and just sort of react to this and also
point out some of the easter eggs and
things that you might have missed
this is in completely in-depth but we
will be going over some of the cool
little things in it and just giving our
thoughts and theories on what exactly is
going on
now i have a theory that warner brothers
dropped this purely because of the
hashtag
restore the snyder verse which has been
trending all week
these guys they forgot the rule if you
give them an inch they'll take a mile
and they didn't realize that handing
over the snyder cut would just lead to
everyone on the internet bombarding them
even more with demanding that everything
gets released
they announced that this trailer was
coming out last night and i went on the
instagram and every single comment was
hashtag restore the snyder booze
so yeah yeah you can't get rid of us
just yet even with this great trailer
now we're going to be breaking it all
down as i said and there might be some
spoilers here so if you don't want in
that room then
get the hell out of here also thanks
thanks for sticking with
me and uh drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
it now let's get into it
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a medal
okay so here you have peacemaker played
by john cena he's obviously getting an
hbo max show
and i know the suicide squad you know
the whole concept of the the comic was
always you don't know who's going to
live who's going to die
that new 52 run especially they kill off
so many characters in it
but the fact that he's getting an hbo
max show kind of guessing he's going to
survive however
it might be a prequel we don't know but
that guy is basically
captain america but a complete idiot
complete
like what captain america symbolizes is
very much patriotism and
like with anything you know you have
your people who are genuinely
good and well intentioned and you also
have your people who take that to the
extreme and just make idiots of
themselves
it doesn't matter what political side
you're part of i'm sure
everyone knows within every single group
of society
there exists people who take things to
the extreme and are also
pretty stupid john cena pretty much
represents that and
he's very much a parody of captain
america which
it's going to be interesting to see i
think james good you know he's got the
style to kind of put this off
and he's just going to be hilarious john
cena's timing
is very very good he's quite dead pan a
lot of the time
and he sort of reminds me a lot of drax
um
because he's quite like drax is very
very very funny
but he's also saying things completely
seriously which i think that peacemaker
is definitely going to be doing
um in the in this truck it also looks
like there's the thinker on the right
um or it might be that your left i don't
know i don't know how this is flipped
around but
he's very much a super villain in the dc
eu um
if you've watched the flash before i'm
sure you'll have seen him but he's
basically a genius
um a master tactician that can plan out
things
and obviously from this trailer he's a
high-value target which
they're basically from the looks of it
they're getting him and then going to
rescue harley quinn
but she can handle herself we've also
got king shark who i think is voiced by
sylvester stallone but that hasn't been
confirmed yet
but it does sound like it defective
dress is a gorgeous it's coming from a
guy that wears a toilet seat on his head
we don't leave one of our own behind
hopefully harley's still alive
no okay and amanda wallace still doing a
usual she's just
bossing people about at least she's not
the the target mine i did like
in the suicide squad one that the first
film how it was you know she it was a
big twist learning that she was the one
that was trying to save
also another thing calling the movie the
first one suicide squad and this one
the suicide squad yeah i know you guys
are pushing for a soft reboot here but
we won't forget and hashtag release the
haircut
and while you add it hashtag restore the
start of this thank you
thank you funny business these are
dangerous people
okay and this place is corto maltese i
believe
um it was i have been told by quite a
few people that it definitely is and
they were they've actually been
working on part of the film and i don't
want to grass them up too much
but i do get sensitive all the time and
they did say that it was corto maltese
which
if you read the dark knight returns it
was basically
the sort of the the dc version of the
cuban missile crisis and
supe i think anyway i'm not not good
with history um but
superman basically went into that place
and just dominated it and
the president was like saying look we've
saved all the people there by sending
superman into
to kill all their their army um and it's
it is
quite an important location in the dc
universe
um it was also named dropped in batman
89
so it's nice that we're finally getting
to see its lovely lovely sandy shores
and it's amazing amazing mediterranean
locales
team
okay so they're here to save holly quid
butcher's fine you know she's
is that the property of mr j tattoo on
her back
i can't really see and but it looks like
it is i'm guessing she didn't get that
removed
obviously in birds of bryce you broke up
with uh mr j
he went off to do the snyder cut in the
nightmare timeline
and we found out holly was dead as well
so lots of things to look forward to
she's also got the j tattoo on her arm
so
even though she's she said goodbye to
the man he's very much still part of her
origin story
um and you know it these tattoos they
they will be a reminder i actually think
in the film that she will sort of bring
up the joker and discuss
how he's impacted her life and they'll
just keep that going throughout the dc
eu
until they decide what to do with jared
leto
you you were gonna save me it was a
really good plan too well i can go back
in
and this is quite interesting because
typically amanda wallace doesn't
send people to rescue other people she's
very much
you get caught behind enemy lines boom
you know what i mean and those that's
totally fine but
obviously dc know that harley quinn is
probably
the most valuable asset right now so
they've sent people in to rescue her
she's the only character that everyone
likes across the board i think
tired and you can still do it that's
patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport and there's
bloodsport with his mask
so it looks like a xenomorph head um he
has a suit that is very
high tech and only he can operate it so
yeah it doesn't look like he has it here
though he's just got the helmet but
i i am kind of interested how they're
going to bring him across here so idris
albert
the rumors behind the scenes were that
he was going to be replacing deadshot
played by will smith um and then they
didn't do that they've
uh they've recap well they've not recast
him but they've put him as this guy
with a xenomorph head so will will smith
be back
will will wild wild west don't know
don't really don't know i don't know
what dc are doing hashtag restore the
snyder verse
[Music]
you know the deal okay and this is
savant i believe
um he's basically a savant if you know
what that means
he um when it comes to technology he can
put he can just pick up anything do
he could be the best youtuber in the
world a lot better than me i'm one of
the worst
but the guy's not being let out of this
cell he's put in a
stone slab of a one with a little ball
and they're just trying to keep him away
from all technological devices i'm
guessing
successfully complete the mission you
get 10 years peter davis in there
don't always deserve your sentence
probably not the best breakdown to be
watching right now but you're here so
we'll watch it
right weasel so yeah this is sean gonna
believe is playing him
um he's james gunn's brother you you'll
recognize him from guardians of the
galaxy
uh he also does the motion capture for
rocket raccoon
what's funny is that disney obviously
when they have animal characters
they've got people like groot baby yoda
and when dc do it they've got a
basically a
horrendous looking rat weasel man
nice
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
can i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous captain boomerang got
some poo on issue i think by the looks
of it
um yeah and we also had of course the
the bomb scene back there as well
and that is armed so it is quite
interesting that they've
kind of shown this going in with a
needle this time i've always got
escape from new york vibes from this um
and
in the original it was sort of playing
on that and this one's a bit more
high-tech by the looks of it we never
got like an x-ray it was never a needle
in the back
it was always just kind of
but maybe they're trying to promote
people getting their covered vaccines so
yeah don't be scared of needles
they don't contain stuff like this so
we've been told
it's in the base of your skull can do
the job
this is the famous suicide captain
boomerang
why okay and this
flag was actually just behind savant
when they pulled up
um i don't yeah it's strange that that
flag is actually part of the movie i
thought that was just a trailer seat you
know what i mean
just have them walking in front of a
flag that seems quite good but you've
got the
you've got the whole line up there
okay and there's tdk and basically
he can take his arms off and hit people
with them
i mean if you look on his chest he's
kind of got a
guy a skeleton doing that so yeah
that'll be
um interesting to see him just pull his
arms off and hit people over the head
with them
you can probably tell from the lineup
these characters they're not really
they're not the a-listers you know
warner brothers they've decided not to
hashtag
restore the snyder verse and they're
just getting the the but
they're scraping the barrel which is a a
lot of the time that's what the suicide
squad do
so i appreciate it i like it but i also
want to hashtag restore the snivers
[Music]
any questions and that's why it's red
band and that did
sound slightly like sylvester stallone
okay and there was polka dot man um he's
actually a batman villain
this guy david i can't pronounce his
last name so
bother great breakdowns here he he's
been in so many things he's been in the
dark knight
ant-man in the wasp ant-man as well
gotham
so many comic book properties and to see
him here it is
you know he's he's sort of almost like
not royalty but if you like comic book
movies especially
you'll have seen this guy about poked up
man he's one of the worst super villains
of all time
he's sort of in league with crazy quilt
he's also pretty crap
in that what the hell is that
these characters were invented during a
time where all the good ones
like the the names had been taken so
batman taken spider-man taken
and they were just going through every
single thing deciding can we can we make
a hero of this
and one day some guy looked at a
polkadot pattern and thought
polkadot man get him out and yeah he's
just going to be a complete joke of a
character
but what a what a movie
okay king shark doing that is ripped
directly from the comics
um there's a scene in the new 52 when
they do
basically that and he holds his hand up
and says hand
so yeah great easter eggs here and pick
up that new 52 run as well because it's
really
really really good yes that is your hand
very good and i believe that she
in the chair is playing rat catcher um
rat catcher two who catches rats
basically and unleashes them on people
sort of like the pied piper
this is actually the daughter of the
original rat catcher so that'll be quite
interesting to see how they bring her
across
that is your hand very good we're all
gonna die
i hope so oh for success
here's the deal we fail the mission you
die we find out any information you give
us is false
you die if we find out okay so
yeah i'm guessing that he is he must be
the vip they must pick him up first and
harley quinn must
be captured they'll have to go rescue
her and then they have this scene
you have personalized license plates you
done
yeah because harley quinn's asking him
questions there so that's kind of the
chronological order there's also a tower
in the background there which is housing
star or the conqueror and that is very
similar
to the outline of the jla volume one
story i think it is it's volume one of
volume two by grant morrison
where starro basically has a tower the
justice league
going to take over him he puts loads of
the little starfishes on people's faces
and these give them
you know he he can control them and
basically it's like
oh crap starro controls to justice
league now
very very good run and i'm guessing that
that's being heavily adapted for this
what no if you cough without covering
your mouth early although that isn't an
open invitation for you to cough without
covering your mouth
yeah don't cough with it without
covering your mouth especially
20 20 21 showed us that mate we don't
need
the preaching of the choir here
what's the plan how am i supposed to
know you're the leader you're supposed
to be decisive
and i've decided that you should eat a
big bag of dicks but this whole beach
was completely covered in dicks and
somebody said i'd eat every dick until
the beach was clean for liberty i would
say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
and that's kind of the the the captain
america pacific i was talking about
before
he's talking about eating dicks and how
he'd happily eat a beachful of dicks
just to be a patriot and unlike him
captain america does sort of question
things from time to time like
uh should should shield really be spying
on everyone
um probably not whereas this guy he he
would be like yeah as long as the
government says it's okay
go ahead and do it
well that's kind of our thing
are you worried very very gory and over
the top
king shark they're ripping a man in half
so it deserves that r rating
i'm gonna get you out of your life i'm
going to get you out of here alive
okay so it looks like they're having a
love um romance as well
i was kind of expecting him to go after
harley just because of the whole
deadshot thing
due to them sort of having a connection
in the comics and
things were hinted at in the first film
but i'm guessing they're going a
different direction
especially after all holly's been
through they've just they've just made a
whole movie about her getting out
one relationship you don't want to go
back into that
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in the
yeah and there's staro the conqueror
definitely
so really really he's basically a kaiju
and but he has mind control abilities
obviously every one of my channels
watched the
the snyder cut this week and there's a
moment in that where steppenwolf puts
spiders over people's faces and it
projects out their thoughts
that is sort of the scenarios version of
star the conqueror
but he's basically he's a golden age
villain almost
the justice league have fought him so
many times
and he's very very important i'm
surprised that they're bringing him
across for the suicide squad but also
great to see him and he is quite a goofy
villain so you do need these kind of
these characters to basically exist with
other goofy characters for it to work in
my opinion you couldn't have this in
robert pattinson's batman
um but it's great to see him here like i
said before he can control people
and he sort of creates a hive mind by
sticking
starfishes on people's faces and he's
from space
so i'm guessing that with this being
centralized to an island that
he it's going to take over the whole
island and then the suicide squad of
whilst this is going on go in get the
thinker and get out
because i'm guessing that the thinker
being such a genius he'll know how to
take down the alien so yeah
great to see him love it
[Music]
i love the rain like angels are
splooting all over us
what a cast list
great okay well yeah thanks for watching
the video
sorry it was a bit crap like i said i'm
doing a lot this weekend
and so keep your eyes on the channel and
thanks for checking out subscribe
buttons right there because we do a lot
the other videos we do this is
embarrassing almost posting this but
thanks for sticking with me and i'll see
you on the next one have a good
friday saturday wherever you are take
care
you